سنتحدث عن اثمن المعادن التي لطالم ارتبطه
بالمناسبات السعيده انه الذهب في هذا
الموضوع من المعروف ان رفع السير الفائده
يكون له تاثير على ارتفاع سعر الدولار وفي
المقابل يؤدي تضخم الى التقليل والحد من
طلب الناس على السلع ما يؤدي الى حدوث
انخفاض في سعر الذهب ولكن ما يحدث في مصر
امر مختلف فالمصريون يتحصنون بالذهب فيسع
التجار الى تحقيق مكاسب كثيره بسوق الذهب
في مصر فيؤدي الى حدوث قفزات كبيره في سعر
الذهب فيما تتبع الدوله جهودا للتحكم في
الاسعار ومنها الغاء رسوم تسمين الذهاب
لتشجيع التصدير وطرح الذهب عيار 14 رسميا
بالاسواق لمكافحه غلاء السعر الاخرى وذلك
بعد ان حقيقه هذه الايام نجحت عندك في
اسوا منها تركيا وايطاليا
[موسيقى]